-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Billie Eilish.
And I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do want to
ask about "SNL,"
but congratulations on your
Oscar nomination.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-For your Bond song.
-I know.
And even being asked to do '
a James Bond song --
it's such a unique thing.
There's no other kind of
theme song where, you know,
through the years,
it's all these iconic musicians
have taken it on.
What was that process like
when you got asked to do it?
Like, who did you have to
meet with in the writing?
-Well, it was -- We made
the song in October of 2019.
So this was
a long, long time ago.
-Yeah, that's a long time.
-It's a long time ago.
-That was a movie that got --
Okay.
-So, 17 when we made it.
I'm now 20.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Interesting.
-Yeah.
-Very, very weird.
Yeah, it was a, like, very long
kind of strategic process.
It wasn't like,
"You got the job, here it is."
We were auditioning,
pretty much.
So it was it was not,
like, an ego thing.
It was like, really,
it's got to be perfect.
We've got to do it right.
They weren't like, "Oh, yeah,
we want Billie Eilish."
It was like, "We want you,"
and we auditioned
and kind of just, like, did our
best and worked really hard.
And it was a lot of, like,
Barbara, and she kind of gave us
the first little bit of
the script,
like, just, like, the opening,
just so that we had a little,
like, taste of the movie.
-Was that helpful
in the writing of the song?
-It was literally
what wrote the song.
-That's wonderful.
-Yeah. It was great.
-And you got to meet with
Daniel Craig.
-Yeah.
-Were you nervous when you --
-Yeah. It's James Bond.
-Yeah, he's James Bond.
-He's James Bond.
-And --
-He's a DILF.
-He is a DILF.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for saying it.
I found, when I say it,
it's weird,
but I want you to know that
I am in full agreement with you.
-You should be.
-But I didn't say it.
I just agreed.
-Those eyes? Girl...
-Yeah.
I mean, those eyes are crazy.
Look, let me just say something.
You have a beautiful blue eyes.
I have beautiful blue eyes.
-You do. You absolutely do.
-But we can't even be in the
same room as that man's eyes.
-No, no, no, no. No.
-These look like pinkeye
compared to him.
-Literally,
you would not believe them.
Like, they look crazy.
-They are crazy.
-When I met him,
I was like, "Whoa!"
Like, they're, like -- It feels
like they're here on him.
Like, this is his face,
and these are his eyes.
-Exactly.
Like, he's -- You want --
If you weren't psyched about it,
you'd say,
"Your eyes are
in my personal space."
-Yeah, yeah, you would!
-The first time he looked at me,
I went, "DILF!"
I didn't --
couldn't stop myself.
-You should get on that.
-Well, I don't know.
-Explore.
-I don't know.
I do feel like it would be
weird if my wife said,
"You get one hall pass,"
and I was like, "Daniel Craig."
-I don't think it
would be weird.
I think you should do it.
-Thank you.
-Do you have a hall pass?
-No.
-Daniel Craig.
-What? Yeah, no.
Well, I'm going to have to go
talk to her about it.
You did a wonderful --
You and Finneas
are going to go
to the Oscars together.
-Yeah.
-That's really cool.
-Is there anything in particular
you're most excited about
the night?
Will you be nervous
the whole day, being a nominee?
-Oh, my God,
it's the scariest thing.
No, I went to
the Oscars in 2020,
right before COVID happened,
and it was, like,
the coolest,
scariest thing I'd ever --
I've never been more nervous
in my life.
"SNL" and the Oscars are, like,
the scariest thing
I've ever experienced.
And -- 'Cause it's not people
that I know, really.
It's actors.
And, also, actors are so
much more eloquent
than musicians.
Like, musicians are, like,
weird and gross and smelly,
and actors are, like, on time
and very -- I don't know.
So it was intimidating.
I was --
Yeah, so I'm very nervous.
-If it goes anywhere
as well as your "SNL,"
you have nothing to worry about.
This was --
A lot of things I loved.
This was my personal favorite.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You and Kate
did this sketch together.
-Yeah.
-And this is very good
still photo, because it --
You never fully broke,
but it did seem like
that was Kate's goal.
-Yeah.
We had trouble with this one.
We -- Yeah.
Well, you know, in the dress
rehearsal, I was tearing up.
I was dying laughing and I felt
like I was going to explode.
It was really
honestly genuinely painful.
Like, you know when
you're not supposed to laugh
and you have to laugh?
It's -- It hurts.
It genuinely hurts.
-Also, watching it
and knowing the show,
there was no release point.
You guys were on camera
the whole time.
There wasn't a time where it
cut away where you could, like,
put yourself back together.
-I know.
And she just was
doing so many things
that were pushing me
over the edge.
Oh, my God, it was infuriating.
-And your your brother had
a fantastic cameo
in the sketch, as well.
-Yeah.
-Now, was he --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it is.
-Is he a hard sell on that
when they asked him to do it
or was he immediately like,
"I'm in"?
-Oh, he was in for sure.
-Yeah. He was great.
-It's "SNL"!
-Yeah, exactly.
-Want a cameo, you get a cameo.
-I want to finish by asking --
Tell everybody what this is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They seem to know.
-Okay.
-So, this is my fragrance.
It's called Eilish,
and it's just --
It speaks for itself.
-Yeah, it does speak for itself.
-It is -- Here.
-Oh, look at that. Beautiful.
And, now, I heard that,
historically,
your connection to the world of
fragrance, of perfume --
this was something
you shared with your father.
-Yes.
-And how were you introduced?
Did he take you to the fanciest
perfume shop in the land?
-Macy's.
Yeah, he took me to Macy's.
Yeah, fragrance and, honestly,
just, like, scent
besides actual fragrances
has been, like, my biggest --
like, one of my --
the biggest parts of my life,
if that even makes sense.
I have what I used to call
a super-sniffer.
You guys watch "Psyche"
when you were little?
Because I love that show.
-I watched it when I was little.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to know --
-Did you ever watch
"Welcome Back, Kotter"?
-No.
-Yeah, I thought.
-No, but I've always had
a severe connection to scent,
and I remember
everything through scents
and people and colors
and all this crazy stuff.
And, like, before I even had
any sort of a career
or the idea of a career,
fragrance was, like,
the most important thing
in my life,
and it, still to this day,
has been.
And I honestly am,
like, using this, like, facade
that I've created of
Billie Eilish
to promote a fragrance.
Like, I'm, like --
I'm using my own clout.
-Well, I think everything
you're using your clout for
is making things better,
not worse.
And thank you so much
for being here.
It was such a delight.
-I'm so honored!
-You guys, that's Billie Eilish.